colin kaepernick continues to trash the
NFL Democrats wait for some actual
first-hand testimony in their
impeachment inquiry and P Budaj edge
jumps into the lead in Iowa I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's how my listeners secure their
internet it's how I secure my internet
join them and expressvpn calm /ban okay
tons to get to today we'll talk
impeachment inquiry in just one second
but here is the thing I think that as
this impeachment inquiry continues it's
pretty obvious to everybody this thing
is breaking down into simple partisan
lines right tribalist lines people
aren't worried about asking questions if
they are on the right people aren't
really worried about asking questions if
they are on the left if you are a
Democrat you believe that Trump should
be impeached of course you believe that
Trump should be impeached literally the
day the man was elected if you are a
Republican you believe that pretty much
no matter what from did it would be very
difficult to get you to agree that he
ought to be impeached which is why when
you talk to a lot of Republicans and you
say okay what is the standard by which
Trump's behavior is impeachable nobody
will actually give you a standard it's a
it's a sort of moving target on the left
the target is moving to meaning what did
he do today well that thing's
impeachable that things one of the
reasons that this is happening is
because the presidency has basically
become a surrogate for our broader
feelings about each other in this
country how you feel about Trump is a
Rorschach test if you're on the left you
see President Trump as a departure from
American norms he's violating everything
right everything that he does is
something different and out of the box
and terrible and new and President Trump
at the same time is a retrograde
throwback to segregation in Jim Crow
president Trump is the worst of all
possible world and thus he must be
ousted and if you're on the right you
look at Trump and what you see mostly is
somebody who is a dam holding back the
raging waters of resentment that are so
evident on the Left a left that wants to
fundamentally change the definition of
Americanism wants to make it so that
fundamental constitutional freedoms are
under assault wants to rewrite the
bargain of what it means to be American
rewrite our basic freedoms freedom of
speech into hate speech laws freedom of
religion into cram downs by government
on your religious institutions and so
Trump is the avatar of we're not going
to do that so if you're on the left you
see Trump is a symbol of everything
wrong with the retrograde America and if
you're on the right you see Trump as a
bulwark against the left that seeks to
rewrite the bargain of Americanism and
destroy everything ensure he ain't the
greatest tool sure he may do things you
don't like but in the end he's the guy
he's on the wall you need him on the
wall and that's why the wall has to
stand and that's what impeachment comes
down to and
we have a dumb cultural controversy
every day we have another idiotic
culture war it reinstates these lines it
reinforces these lines because the more
the left pushes on something stupid the
more the right says I don't care who's
on the wall but I need somebody on that
wall and at the same time the more the
left picks issues where the right
opposes the left says oh well you know
it's because these people are terrible
and awful and that's why Trump should be
impeached and that's why we need
somebody who is wait we need to rewrite
the entire American bargain we need to
tear this thing out by its roots so to
understand people's views of Trump you
actually have to understand people's
views of where America is more generally
okay so that's why these culture wars
matter people tend to think the cultural
words don't matter and they tend to boil
down Trump's performance in 2016 or in
2020 they tend to boil that down to
economic factors and so the going theory
has been that Trump won in 2016 because
there were a lot of economically
depressed areas particularly in the
heartland of America that were
disproportionately white dying
manufacturing towns that have been left
behind by Barack Obama and free trade
and that and therefore they turn to
Trump in a moment of panic and they
still like Trump and this is what the
theory says the theory says that because
of economics of under a bunch of high
school educated white men who can't get
jobs in the big city are tending toward
Trump and therefore as we move into 2020
so long as the economy is good so long
as Trump is attempting to prove that he
is bringing jobs back to these
manufacturing areas they're likely to
stick with him anyway right it's all
economics but the truth is that most of
Trump's appeal is not in fact an
economic appeal sure that plays into it
obviously the economy always plays into
it but if Trump were to lose in 2020 in
large part that would be a measure of
people's take on Trump personally not on
the state of the economy and more
importantly Trump only is able to win
this what the left doesn't understand
Trump is able to win not because of
economic issues right the economy was
already doing fairly well in 2016 Trump
was able to win in 2016 because the
Democrats have declared culture war on
people in the middle and on the right in
this country and so every dumb culture
war actually cuts in Trump's favor
you know people on the Left are sick of
hearing people on the right say this is
why Trump won but the real reason that
Trump won is because of the culture wars
and so every culture war you guys
declare that falls apart on you on
impact whether
the Covington Catholic kids or whether
it is the Justice Cavanaugh hearings any
of those are going to cut in Trump's
favor so in a second I'm gonna bring you
the latest couple of culture wars that
are important I'm gonna explain why they
are important even though they are
indeed incredibly stupid they are stupid
issues if these are dumb issues that
really should not divide Americans these
should be issues that that really are
not on the public mind they shouldn't be
on the front page of newspapers and yet
they are we're gonna get to those in
just one second first let's talk about a
fantastic fantastic company so the fact
is that every morning I wake up wake up
early with my kids got to get them ready
for school my wife has to go off to the
hospital and work as a doctor because as
you know she's a doctor
and that means I need a cup of coffee
when I say I need a cup of coffee I mean
like I will not function if I do not
have my black rifle coffee
well US service members go with how many
of life's simple pleasures when
stationed overseas a good cup of coffee
doesn't have to be one of them say thank
you for your service without actually
saying it by buying a bag of premium
small batch of black rifle coffee at
company coffee for yourself BRCC
will donate a bag to be shipped to be
deployed u.s. servicemembers throughout
November for each coffee purchase black
rifle coffee company will give a bag of
their limited time offer holiday rows to
troops overseas to be delivered by
Christmas supporting the troops has
never been easier or more delicious let
me tell you again I start my day every
day with a cup of black rifle coffee
my favorite roast just black because I
mean it is what it is I mean it's not
lying about it with tons of different
roasts to choose from black rifle ships
the best roast to order coffee directly
to your door and let me tell you
something the dudes of black rifle
coffee they are awesome
awesome guys I know them I know people
founded the company they are great when
you support the company you're
supporting them and you can support the
military to visit black rifle coffee
comm /a been give to get 20% off your
first purchase and help black rifle
donate a bag of delicious coffee to our
troops serving overseas that's black
rifle coffee calm / Ben give again black
rifle coffee calm / Ben give go check
them out awesome awesome dudes and when
you support them you support the show
black rifle coffee calm / I've been
given ok so dumb culture war of the
weekend number one remember Colin
Kaepernick mer hasn't been in the NFL
for like three years remember how he was
benched for Blaine Gabbert
because he was a bad quarterback
remember how he went to the Super Bowl
and everybody's like this guy is the
future of the NFL and then he started to
suck and he got benched and all of a
sudden he was kneeling on the sidelines
and he was
the headlines and then remember nobody
would sign him because it turns out he's
not only not a very good quarterback but
he's very polarizing to audiences and
turns out the NFL is in the
entertainment business and then it turns
out that Colin Kaepernick is given a
million-dollar contract by Nike to
about America basically he's given a
million-dollar contract by Nike to talk
about how brave he is for kneeling on
the sidelines while receiving a
million-dollar contract from Nike for
kneeling on the sidelines and then he
gets to whine about the Betsy Ross flag
on Nike sneakers and Betsy and Nike
immediately pulls the Betsy Ross flag
off because for some reason the Betsy
Ross flag which stood behind Barack
Obama and his 2008 inauguration
apparently that Betsy Ross flag is
deeply deeply racist while the entire
media buys into the Colin Kaepernick
myth and the entire media the sports
media the news media he is a victim he's
a victim in America he's a victim of
brute racism and American society's
unwillingness to have tough
conversations about things like police
violence which we've been having as a
society ongoing for now no decades at
this point okay so Colin Kaepernick was
a great hero of the Republic according
to the left and this is a dumb culture
war because President Trump got involved
and he said no he's not a culture hero
and also the NFL should fire anybody who
does this and that of course is not the
right solution and it turns into this
big culture war about whether you like
Colin Kaepernick or whether you don't
like Colin Kaepernick now the whole
thing is stupid and the reason the whole
thing is stupid
is because the vast majority of
Americans are on the same page on most
of these issues in a reasonable way
meaning the vast majority of Americans
think that the police are doing their
best in trying to do a good job the vast
majority of Americans also believe that
if a police officer does something
racist that police officer should be
fired and if he does so in the course of
his job he should be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law the vast
majority of Americans are also in favor
of the American flag and do not see the
American flag as a symbol of repression
or oppression particularly not in 2019
when we live in the freest most
prosperous country in the history of the
world these several propositions the
vast majority of Americans agree about
now when it comes to should somebody be
allowed to kneel for the national anthem
there are some people who say yes some
people who say no but the general
perception in America is if you want to
kneel for the national anthem
go for it but you look like a douchebag
right I mean that is the general
perception in the United States of
America and a perception with which I
broadly agree right you're free to do it
just like you're free to burn the flag
but also it makes you a jerk okay so all
of these things can be true but the
media insists
Kaepernick is in fact the greatest
wisest among us than when he was on the
field wearing pictures on his socks of
cops as pigs and somehow this was okay
and people on the right went nuts
because they said okay this is we're
being gas-lit here we're being told that
this person is trying to improve America
you don't improve America by kneeling
for the national anthem and wearing
socks that have a cop as a pig on them
yes a Colin Kaepernick plays this thing
all the way to the end ride plays this
string all the way out picks up his
check from Nike rips on the American
flag rips on the Betsy Ross flag and he
was not a very good quarterback in the
dirty little secret is it the reason
that he was benched is cuz he was a bad
quarterback not because of the kneeling
he was benched before the kneeling and
then it turns out that as a not very
good quarterback who also happens to
bring in tremendous amounts of public
liability with him a lot of places were
like do we really want the hassle of
this guy especially because if we then
let him go he's going to complain that
we are being mean to him on the basis of
his race okay so all of this comes to a
head this weekend because Colin
Kaepernick was given a workout by the
NFL the NFL offered to organize a
private workout for him and invited
every single league every single team in
the league to attend according to ESPN
according to Amanda Presta Shaka Mon
reporting for the daily wire the session
according to ESPN allowed Kaepernick an
on-field workout and an interview which
would be both taped and made available
to all teams
moreover the workout was set up to
provide teams anonymity so if they
watched Kaepernick and didn't want him
they wouldn't catch flack this was done
to encourage more teams to attend the
event thus helping the quarterback
secure a position but this was not good
enough for Kaepernick so Kaepernick
cancelled the workout abruptly over the
weekend on Saturday about a half hour
before the session was supposed to begin
apparently because he wasn't allowed to
bring his own camera crew because he
wanted to grandstand and the NFL said no
if you really want to work in the NFL
then we are going to tape it and all of
the teams will show up but you're not
allowed to grandstand and call out to
Miami Dolphins for not signing you or
something according to CBS News the
workout was originally set for 3:00 p.m.
it was to be held at the Atlanta Falcons
practice facility in Flowery Branch at
2:30 representatives for the free agent
quarterback informed the league that
Kaepernick would instead be conducting
the workout at 4 p.m. at drew High
School in Riverdale Georgia according to
CBS News so Kaepernick attended his own
workout in a Kunta Kinte Kinte t-shirt
comparing himself to the Defiant slave
from the movie
Roots because when I think of Colin
Kapernick I think of a person who was
forced into involuntary servitude and
then whipped I mean that that's that's
why colin kaepernick Kunta Kinte exactly
the same if you're an insane person now
of course there's an iconic scene in the
film roots where Kunta Kinte is whipped
by his master for refusing to
acknowledge his slave named Toby a
statement from Kaepernick's agent and
lawyer released before the workout
blamed a liability waiver and the NFL
denying the quarterback the opportunity
to bring his own camera crew to the
workout for their decision to ditch the
event with such little notice also they
used as an excuse the fact that the NFL
forced him to sign a liability waiver
okay which is a normal liability waiver
because if he gets hurt in the course of
this they don't want the NFL to be sued
according to the NFL the waiver
Kaepernick threw a fit over was a
standard liability waiver based on the
waiver used by national invitational
camp at all NFL Combine and by NFL clubs
when trying out free agent players also
Kaepernick didn't inform them of his
request to have his own personal camera
crew attend the event until Friday night
they said we heard for the first time
last night around the same time we heard
from Nike that Collin wanted to bring
his own video crew we heard for the
first time this afternoon that Collin
wanted to open the event to all media
and said this has been his routine he
came out after his training session
apparently Scout said that he was
mediocre that he still has an arm
strength which was never his problem his
problem is that he couldn't make a
secondary read right his problem is that
he would run before he actually did his
read progression and that he was not
accurate in throws downfield those were
his big problems he had a lot of arm
strength always he still has his arm
strength he's 32 years old and he's a
strong guy I mean why not okay but there
was Colin Kaepernick afterward
proclaiming himself a hero of the
Republic for three years I've been
denying for three years we all know why
I came out here showed it today in front
of everybody we have nothing to hide so
we're waiting for the 32 owners 32 teams
Roger Goodell all of them to stop
running stop running from the truth stop
running from the people around here
we're ready to play ready to go anywhere
my agent Jeff nalli is ready to talk to
any team in
you a team at any time I've been ready
I'm stay ready and I'll continue to be
ready okay so in other words the way
that you are auditioning for teams to
hire you is by being a head case in a
pain in the ass I mean that really is
what this is because this is not anymore
about police brutality or free speech or
anything like that
this is about why would if you're a team
owner why would you possibly hire a guy
that's probably a third string
quarterback who if he does not play is
immediately going to go to the media and
suggest that you are a brutal vicious
racist okay so Stephen a Smith over at
ESPN who is no right winger okay Stephen
a is no right winger he slammed Colin
Kaepernick over this and then he got a
bunch of flack from the left because
this is how our dumb society works
here's Steven Naismith going after
Kaepernick and saying this is all
grandstanding nonsense
Colin Kaepernick wants to change the
venue Kylie Kaplan wants his own
receivers Colin Kaplan was the video
thinks himself Colin Kaepernick wants
the media this Kollek a big comedian
can't find him he don't know interviews
he talked to nobody I mean you can't
find him but he wants to do in it he
wants to be the available now he don't
want to play he wants to be a martyr but
guess what
it ain't working this time so Steven
Naismith then gets an enormous amount of
flack from the left because he said a
true thing but by the way this is the
consensus even with a lot of folks on
the Left who are concerned about racial
issues from a left-leaning perspective
there's a report yesterday that jay-z
told Sports Illustrated that he is quote
disappointed with Colin's actions and
believes he turned a legitimate work out
into a publicity stunt jay-z has been a
longtime kaepernick supporter apparently
he was rumored to have had a hand in
organizing the Saturday workout with the
NFL athlete to help the athlete secure a
position with the team again according
to Amanda Presta Chaka mow over at Daily
wire as noted by the undefeated jay-z's
Carter's Roc Nation entertainment
company signed on with the NFL this
summer to leave the organization music
and entertainment endeavors asked by a
reporter of he'd kneel or stand for the
national anthem
jay-z responded earlier this year I
think we're past kneeling I think as
time is going to actionable items I
think everyone knows what the issue is
we're done with that okay next where are
we moving on next okay so here's the
rights response to all of this right we
know all this from the beginning and
where were all of you like really we all
move
is grandstanding nonsense from the very
beginning that this was Colin
Kaepernick's way of getting a headline
and making money so where were all of
you or was this just another way to
divide the country for purposes of
dividing the country for the left it was
a way of dividing the country of our
dumb issue where again there's broad
agreement you're allowed to kneel for
the anthem you're allowed to burn the
flag it also makes you a jerk to do so
also we all agree that if the police act
in a racist way that is a bad thing if
we if the police do something wrong they
should be prosecuted but the police are
overwhelmingly doing their best to make
cities safer like we all there's a vast
amount of agreement on these issues and
what the left does too often and this is
true in the case of the cultural left of
Kaepernick what the left does too often
is they pick a bad example and then if
you oppose their bad example they say
that you oppose the underlying idea all
right so they pick a jerk like
Kaepernick and then if you say I don't
like what Kaepernick is doing I think
he's doing something bad doing something
wrong and doing something that is bad
for the country then they say well it's
because you don't care about police
racism and this is the routine that the
left would like to play and the rights
response to this typically is well go
you know a few right that that is the
right response to all of this okay we're
seeing more of these incredibly stupid
cultural controversies brought up by the
left and this is why again this all
plays into the Trump impeachment inquiry
because how you see Trump is basically
deciding how you see this impeachment
inquiry nobody sees this is a
nonpartisan effort to get to the bottom
of the matter nobody sees this as a real
defense of the Constitution everybody
sees this for what it is which is a
deeply political exercise and where you
come down on that political exercise is
largely dependent and where you come
down in these culture wars I'll train
another dumb cultural controversy of the
day in just one second first let's talk
about upgrading your employees so now
let's say that you have an employee I
know it gets hit a lot like an employee
named Nick and let's say he has a wide
variety of skills from hunting in the
Amazon to carving menorahs out of
particular types of wood but let's say
also that this this Nick fellow let's
say that at the time when he's supposed
to be cutting audio or listening to
audio he's actually doing yoga in the
back rooms in front of all of the other
producers who are cutting audio well
let's say that you wanted to upgrade
over Nick let's say that he just went
away for a couple of days and he came
back and there was somebody who replaced
him what would be the best way to do
that zip recruiter com zip recruiter
doesn't depend on
it's finding you it finds them for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast if you post on
super cooter you can count on being able
to at least see some resumes that are
going to match what you're looking for
and zip recruit will help you file
through those with results like that
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter an
equality candidate within the very first
day see why zip recruiter is effective
for businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web addresses
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily wires hip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire okay so the other dum cultural
controversy of the weekend so now
chick-fil-a has been forced to stop
giving money to charities that don't
support the LGBT agenda according to
business as chick-fil-a expands globally
and it's more liberal parts of the u.s.
the chicken chain plans to change which
charities it donates to after years of
bad press and protests from the LGBT
community beginning next year
chick-fil-a will move away from its
current philanthropic structure
according to busines
chick-fil-a has never discriminated
against a gay person in their service
ever okay if a gay person comes in with
their partner if a transgender person
comes in and wants a chicken sandwich
nobody behind the counter is like sorry
you can't eat here instead what happened
is that the corporate heads of
chick-fil-a were giving money to wait
for it wait for it the Salvation Army
the brutal evil terrible Salvation Army
which by the way was subjected to yet
more threats of boycott over the last
couple of weeks when the British singer
Ellie Goulding suggested she wouldn't
sing at halftime of the Dallas Cowboys
football game unless the Salvation Army
disassociated from its opposing anti
LGBT agenda of which there is none so
let's just make clear right now in
America if you hold particular views on
particular subjects and you give your
own charity to those views but in your
business life you service all customers
the same that is not good enough for the
left the left wants to control how you
give your money if you politically
disagree and want to ban you from public
places and then you wonder why people
are resonating to Trump that is the
reason why people are resonating to
Trump mean poll numbers show by the way
that a lot of the people who move to
Obama trunk did so on the basis of
cultural concerns not on the basis of
race as the left would like to suggest
on the basis of
cultural concerns on the basis that the
left has moved so radical so fast that
if you are in any business and in your
private life you give to a church and
that church happens to stand by the
biological and logical standard that
there's such a thing as a male and such
a thing as a female that you will be
boycotted for that we've seen the left
come after actors like Chris Pratt for
the great sin of going to a traditional
church that suggests that men and women
are different how dare he
how dare he announced early and
chick-fil-a because it's a company and
wants to make money is caving to the
cultural left and the predictable result
of this is going to be that people on
the right are gonna do the same thing
people on the right are going to look at
left-leaning companies you know
companies that per dot provide great
product but are also backing causes that
people on the right don't like right
they're giving money to various lefty
organizations and they're gonna say okay
well fine we're gonna ban you from our
cities you want to ban chick-fil-a from
the Chicago Airport okay well we're
going to ban your organization from the
Birmingham Airport but you will see this
move by the right and it will be
perfectly appropriate by the standards
to the left now I don't like any of this
I think it's bad for the country I think
that you should go eat the best chicken
sandwich you can and you shouldn't think
too much about whether the people who
are making you the chicken sandwich have
views different from your own because if
we start segregating into I'm only gonna
do business with people with whom I
agree that that further divides the
country in pretty terrible ways
obviously there are limits to that and
if you believe that the person is giving
money to a Nazi organization or
something you know something that is
completely outside what we would call
the Overton Window another thing that
there's a somewhat a maybe maybe I can
even see the argument that you shouldn't
even look into that right that it's
better for the country if you don't
worry about at all the viewpoint of the
person whose company you are patronizing
the reason being again that we do live
in a common policy and if you want the
best products at the best possible price
then you should stop worrying about what
people think it's a free country and
these sort of cultural crackdown that is
happening right now where we are
supposed to not patronize the businesses
that are disassociated from the views of
the owners that that that leads to a
very bad logic now I'm not talking about
businesses where the view the owners
viewpoint actually filters in so for
example if you were a gay person and
chick-fil-a
we're discriminating against gay people
in a service like they didn't want to
serve gay people I think it's totally
appropriate for you to say I'm not
eating there but if you won't go to a
company because you've researched the
CEO and you disagree with the political
viewpoint of the CEO but the service of
the company is exactly the same for you
as anybody else and they're not
discriminating in their service that
their political viewpoint doesn't make a
difference in their service I think
there's a good case to be made in
America that you basically should stop
worrying so much about what other people
think and start worrying about whether
they are providing you the service and
good to which you have contracted that
probably better for the country but the
left only applies this to one side of
the aisle obviously and so now they're
now going after chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
president and chief operating officer
Tim Katsopolis
said in an interview with Biz now
there's no question we know that as we
go into new markets we need to be clear
about who we are there are lots of
articles in news casts about chick-fil-a
and we thought we needed to be clear
about our message so they're no longer
going to support the Salvation Army the
Fellowship of Christian Athletes or the
Paul Anderson youth home all of which
sparked criticism in the past from LGBT
community thanks to the organization's
stances on homosexuality because the
Salvation Army isn't a clear and open
supporter of same-sex marriage so unless
you celebrate the left's cultural goals
they will boycott you and not only will
they boycott you they will get your
restaurants banned from public spaces
the several US airports have actually
rejected chick-fil-a from concessions
deals earlier this year the landlord of
the first chick-fil-a in the UK
announced eight days into its lease the
pop-up-menu would not be welcome to
extend all because of the company's
perceived anti LGBT stance okay so if
the left declares war on you simply
because of who you give charity to if
the left declares war on you not because
your business is doing anything that is
wrong or evil but simply because you
yourself are giving the money that you
have earned from that business to a
political cause the Left disagrees with
well then obviously you're gonna throw
up a middle finger to these people
obviously your goal is going to be to to
fight back against anyone who seeks to
ruin your life and your business on the
basis that you disagree with them not
even in the practice of your business
but in your personal life and how you
spend your money your own money your
corporate profits right if that's the
way this is going to work then the
divides in the country are going to grow
ever stronger okay so all of this is the
backdrop to the impeachment inquiry now
all of this is the backdrop to the
latest in the impeachment inquiry
and so everything is polarized so over
the weekend Attorney General William Bar
gave a public speech all about the
Democrats and the Republicans and the
impeachment inquiry and Barr said
Democrats are breaching the rules here
right they keep talking about how Trump
is breaching the rules and ruining
everything it's Democrats who are
breaching the rules and running
everything here's William Barr the fact
of the matter is that in waging a
scorched-earth no-holds-barred war of
resistance against this administration
it is the left that is engaged in the
systematic shredding of norms and
undermining the rule of law okay so Barr
got all sorts of flack for this how
could he say that the left is
undermining the rule of law well he can
say that pretty easily considering that
the left has routinely shredded the rule
of law the left wants to change over the
Senate they want to get rid of the
electoral college Stacey Abrams
continues to insist she's governor of
Georgia with the backing of the entire
left wing and the Democratic leadership
the Democrats even in their pursuit of
the impeachment inquiry to things like
issue subpoena requests but not formally
and then claim that the Republicans are
stonewalling they try to violate the
rules by going after Grand Jury
background material from the Muller
investigation which is supposed to be
hidden by law right the idea that the
right that the Trump administration is
willy-nilly breaking law and the left is
just abiding by law is obviously untrue
and everybody can see it and you can see
it in the impeachment inquiry too you've
got Adam Schiff who has been going
around saying that he hasn't made up his
mind on impeachment yet and then over
the weekend who's speaking at a
California Democratic Party event and he
literally said about Donald Trump we're
gonna send that charlatan back where he
came from so does anybody take this
entire impeachment inquiry seriously as
a matter of law as a matter of
protecting the Constitution how can you
and the head of the House Intelligence
Committee who's chairing this whole
impeachment inquiry is a fraud like Adam
chef that charlatan in the White House
back to the golden throne he came from
and you know why because we vote how do
we build another big beautiful wave we
vote okay but does anyone really believe
that he is relegating his hatred of
Trump getting rid of the charlatan
throwing him sending him back to the
golden throne that he's relegating that
too simple voting and get-out-the-vote
efforts where does that bleed into the
impeachment inquiry and then when you
watch a Nancy Pelosi why do you think so
many on the writer going okay so this is
all part of a piece the same sort of
folks who backed Colin Kaepernick's
charade the same sort of folks who would
like to ban chick-fil-a from the airport
are the same sort of folks who are
insisting that they stand for the
Constitution when they really just want
to get rid of the duly elected president
of the United States this is the
emotional response with right now none
of this answers the questions as to
whether Donald Trump violated the law or
violated his presidential duties right
I've said all along they're still open
questions to be asked about Trump's
behavior with regard to Ukraine but the
reason the American public is breaking
down into hard and fast dividing lines
is because the impeachment effort is now
just part of the broader culture war and
you can see it when the Democrats talk
about this stuff like Nancy Pelosi was
on TV over the weekend and choose ask
specifically what impeachable offense
Trump committed and she literally cannot
answer the question she does not know
the answer to this question and yet she
has informed us that she is operating on
the up and up and this isn't a partisan
inquiry at all the Constitution defines
an impeachable offense as treason
bribery or high crimes and misdemeanors
what do you think applies to this case
we are unfolding the facts that's what
an inquiry is about oh we're unfolding
the fad oh I see it's what the inquiry
is about yet Pelosi will also say the
what Trump did was much worse than what
Nixon did Nixon was about to be
impeached when he quit so here is Nancy
Pelosi suggesting at the same time that
while they don't have all the answers
yet they're trying to get to the answers
guys in a nonpartisan way but also what
Trump did is much worse than what Nixon
did just as Adam Chef says yeah I'm
nonpartisan I'm really just interested I
don't I haven't made up my mind yet but
let's send that charlatan back to the
golden throne from once he came there's
Nancy Pelosi doing the same routine so
much worse than even what Richard Nixon
did but at some point Richard Nixon
cared about the country enough to
recognize
that this could not continue she's
suggesting that Trump should resign on
the basis that Nancy Pelosi doesn't like
him right and then my favorite is that
the Democratic one and like the
Democrats are there's an impeachment
inquiry in search of an impeachable
crime so you end up with it from the
Democrats is over the weekend they shift
their impeachment direction and they
move away from the Ukraine activity and
toward the fact that President Trump
said a mean tweet about Murray Ivanovich
now I have a lot of sympathy for Murray
Ivanovich it sounds like she got
railroaded it does it sounds like Murray
Ivanovich was working as ambassador to
Ukraine and that she may have been
unsympathetic to Trump but that she
didn't do anything that really violated
her job description and that there were
people like Rudy Giuliani who were
feeding information from people who
didn't like Jovanovic to Trump and from
fired her now
Trump's allowed to do that if you're
Murray Ivanovich and you're sitting
there going I didn't do anything wrong
why did I get fired I have some sympathy
for that but Trump attacking her and
saying that she was a bad ambassador so
I fired her that is not witness
intimidation that's what the Democrats
tried to claim last week and over the
weekend they tried to blow up this
narrative even bigger here was Nancy
Pelosi suggesting that Trump tweeting
out his random stupid commentary on
Murray Ivanovich on Twitter somehow
amounts to an impeachable offense and
witness intimidation and is very
significant here's Pelosi being
completely false about all of this was
just his opinion he wasn't trying to
intimidate what do you think what the
president and perhaps some at the White
House have to know that the words of the
president weigh a ton
they are very significant and he should
not frivolously throw out insults but
that's what he does I think part of it
is his own insecurity as an impostor I
think he knows full well that he's in
that office way over his head and so he
has to diminish everyone else
okay she's trollin trollin trollin
though the rivers swollen keep them
doggies trolling raw she's trying to
drive from not sir I mean that that is
what she is trying to do and so are
members of the media right here's Chuck
Todd over the weekend suggesting the
president Trump attacking Ivanovitch was
quote-unquote authoritarian
authoritarian he's the head of the
executive branch he wants to be an
authoritarianism Lee declare he's not
going to enforce immigration law for a
broad swath of people living in the
United States like Barack Obama did or
theoretically his eye
could be militarized against his
political opponents Chuck Todd says
though the Trump tweeting is
authoritarian his
stream-of-consciousness
Twitter feed you can tell that he's
rattled and that exposed itself really
with with his tweet about the former
ambassador in the middle of the in the
middle of the testimony on Friday
Peggy that is what struck me about all
this weakness to sort of realize it's
consumed him he can't compartmentalize
Bill Clinton and compartmentalised in
ways that some of us are like how do you
do that right almost overly so this guy
can't at all to the point he had to
force himself into me hearing what he
did in the hearing was was what
authoritarian people do that was just a
rough moment
really it was authoritarian also
remember how Bill Clinton compartment
slides by shooting a camel in the ass in
Sudan in the middle of the impeachment
inquiry that was really good he had like
a baby milk factory in the middle of the
impeachment inquiry he'd really
compartmentalize did Bill Clinton Mao
just magic okay so in just a second
we're going to get to the big weakness
that remains in the Democrats
impeachment case and how they're
attempting to rectify this weakness but
you're gonna have to be a subscriber in
order to see the rest of the show live
if you're not already a subscriber
you're really missing out head on over
to daily wire calm slash subscribe for
as little as ten bucks a month you get
our articles ad free access to all of
our live broadcasts our full show
library select bonus content and our
exclusive daily wire app which is a
pretty great feature if you haven't
checked it out yet if you choose the new
All Access plan you'll get all that plus
the legendary leftist ears tumblr and
our brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis we have all
these magical things happening for you
so stop depriving yourself come join the
fun over at daily wire comm for $9.99 a
month you get that subscription for 99
bucks a year you get this the greatest
in all beverage vessels the leftist
here's how to call tumblr so good that
Elizabeth Warren is copying it go check
us out over at daily where to come we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so what is the big hole that
Democrats have in this impeachment
inquiry the big holes they don't have
anybody in the room but Chris Wallace
points this out over the weekend he's
talking to a Democratic Congress person
he says listen you know for all of your
speculation for all the people you've
had testified not a single person that
you've taught you've talked about yet
has actually been in a room with Donald
Trump and until you find somebody who's
in the room with Donald Trump you don't
have the material makings for an
impeachment inquiry here's Wallace
making that point Richard Nixon the
impeachment investigation he was never
of course formally impeach he resigned
first would have been nearly as powerful
without John Dean I'm not sure the
Clinton impeachment would have been
nearly as powerful without the blue
dress if you don't have anybody who can
take us into the Oval Office it seems to
me that creates a big problem okay and
that of course is exactly true and that
is why this week's testimony is only
going to matter so far as Gordon someone
so Gordon Sunland is the EU ambassador
he's the one who's been having
conversations with Trump throughout this
entire process with regard to aid to
Ukraine he's the one who switched his
testimony originally he said there was
no quid pro quo then he said no I think
they're kind of was a quid pro quo his
testimony is all that's going to matter
that's the point that is made by
representative jim Himes democrat he
says garret he says Gordon someone may
have an unpleasant legal future before
him so I love that they are saying that
Trump tweeting about Murray Ivanovitch
is his witness intimidation but a
Democrat who sits on the House
Intelligence Committee I believe can
threaten the witness right he's I mean
he's threatening him right he may have a
very unpleasant legal future in front
he's threatening the witness but that's
not witness intimidation you have we do
have people who were in the room chief
amongst them ambassador Sunderland we
will say I'm not gonna try to prejudge
his testimony but he yes he has amended
his testimony look it was not lost on
ambassador Sunland what happened to the
president's close associate Roger stone
for lying to Congress to Michael Cohen
for lying to Congress my guess is that
ambassador Sandlin is going to do his
level best to tell the truth because
otherwise he may have a very unpleasant
legal future in in front of him not
witness intimidation guys not witness
intimidation Democratic Representative
Shaun Maloney
he's also counting on Gordon
some money says that sunland's testimony
will show solicitation of a bribe the
President of the United States used
taxpayer-funded military assistance to
pressure a foreign leader to help him in
his reelection campaign that is
solicitation of a bribe and that is an
impeachable offense listed in the
Constitution and sadly my friend Chris
Stewart is going to get his wish this
week when we get a testimony from
Ambassador Sandlin who who at the
president's instruction told the
Ukrainians either go to a microphone and
announce an investigation of the Biden's
or there will not be military assistance
that is solicitation of a bribe
okay so we will see whether Gordon
sunland indeed fulfills the expectations
of the Democrats he is the key witness
at this point and the Democrats again
have not yet had anybody testify as to
Trump's intent sunlen presumably
provides a window into that so his
testimony actually will matter if you
think any of this is anything but a
basic impeachment hold on but just a
partisan hold that meanwhile President
Trump is pledging it this week that he
may actually give written testimony that
he will consider strongly testifying and
writing in the impeachment probe now if
you're his lawyer this is the only way
you're going to allow him to testify
right I mean you're not going to allow
Trump to get in front of a microphone
that would be just the stupidest thing
that any lawyer could do I mean Trump is
an awful witness if you're a lawyer
because he has a norm he has a natural
trumpian tendency to exaggerate and brag
and boast and say dumb things I mean
that that's what Trump does so giving
written testimony is exactly what he did
in the motor case it is not unexpected
that he would suggest that he could do
so with regard to Nancy Pelosi he said
on Monday he will strongly consider
testifying and writing as part of the
impeachment inquiry at the outside of a
week in which eight current and former
officials are scheduled to publicly
testify about his controversial actions
regarding Ukraine according to The
Washington Post in mourning tweets Trump
said he might take up House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi on a suggestion she made
over the weekend
Trump also claimed the rules of the
inquiry had been rigged by Pelosi and
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff apparently Democrats are
seeking to prove that Trump leveraged
military assistance apparently Senator
Ron Johnson also said that the
whistleblower source is exposed to
things that didn't need to be exposed
from the White House national security
official told house investigators that
Gordon Sunland was acting at
behest so it's going to be a spicy week
for the Trump administration meanwhile
the the and as I say Sunland is going to
be the key witness here because none of
the other people who were in the room
with Trump are slated to testify at this
point meaning John Bolton is not slated
to testify at this point despite the
fact that Bolton and Trump apparently
met privately over the withheld aid
according to testimony from one of these
White House officials Timothy Morrison
who is an aide to the State Department
he said the extent of my recollection is
that ambassador Bolton simply said he
wasn't ready to do it as far as holding
up the aide now whether Bolton testifies
or not is still up in the air Sunland
however is booked he has already
testified behind closed doors and so a
lot is going to come down to Gordon
Sunland meanwhile president Trump is
very angry at Mike Pompeo apparently
he's raging at my Pompeo because members
of the State Department have come for
and testified against Trump well Pompeo
can't control that I mean it's not up to
Pompeo whether members of the State
Department testify presumably he's
already told people he doesn't want them
to testify Trump has already said that
obviously according to NBC News Trump is
fumed for weeks the Pompeo is
responsible for hiring State Department
officials whose congressional testimony
threatens to bring down his presidency
the president confronted Pompeo about
the officials during lunch at the White
House October 29th those familiar with
the matter said inside the White House
the view is that Trump just felt like
Ranier people in apparently Trump
particularly blames Pompeo for tapping a
bill Taylor in June to be the top US
diplomat in Ukraine but then again in
June
Pompeyo didn't realize that Trump was
going to just radically change Ukraine
policy and decide that who's gonna
withhold the Ukrainian aid so as I said
all along there are open questions in
all of this the problem is that
everything is so partisan and so
polarized at this point that nobody
takes it seriously and frankly I'm not
sure that they should because it is so
partisan and so polarized okay with all
of that said the foreign scene continues
to be incredibly chaotic over in Iran
protests have reached a hundred cities
according to The Associated Press in
Iran supreme leader on sunday cautiously
backed the government's decision to
raise gasoline prices by 50 percent
after days of widespread protests
calling those who attack public property
during demonstrations thugs signaling a
potential crackdown loom the government
has shut down Internet access across the
nation to stanch demonstrations that
took place in reported 100
cities and towns images published by
state and semi official media showed the
scale of the damage and images of burned
gas stations and banks torched vehicles
and roadways littered with debris there
have been accusations that Iran is using
deadly force on protesters Iranian
authorities on Sunday raised the
official death toll in the violence to
at least three attackers targeting a
police station in the western city of
kermanshah on Saturday killed an officer
according to the state-run irn a news
agency lawmaker said another person was
killed in a suburb of Tehran Ayatollah
Ali Khamenei said some lost their lives
some places were destroyed without
elaborating so people have been ignoring
in the media the fact they're roiling
protests against the Iranian government
that's been ongoing for literally years
at this point which is good news for the
West you know wildly while the Europeans
are ripping president from for the
sanctions while the press is ripping
from for the sanctions the fact is that
this is significantly curtailed 2-runs
ability to control even its own country
and it is cut down on Iran's ability to
fund terror abroad it is amusing I will
say for the New York Times to report
that Tehran has maximized its power in
Iraq at the same time the New York Times
has been militating in favor of giving
billions of dollars to Tehran in cash
according to the New York Times big
story in The New York Times over the
weekend hundreds of leaked intelligence
reports shed light on a shadow war for
regional influence apparently Iran has
been exerting its influence in rock
which of course everybody knew I mean
the fact is that Iran has intervened in
Iraq so much that hundreds if not
thousands of American troops died at the
behest of Ronnie and militias throughout
the Iraq war according to the New York
Times in mid-october with the unrest
swirling in Baghdad a familiar visitor
Swift slipped quietly into the Iraqi
capital the city had been under siege
for weeks as protesters marched in the
streets demanding an end to corruption
and calling for the ouster of the prime
minister Adil absolu mahdi in particular
they denounced the outsized influence of
their neighbor Iran on Iraqi politics
burning Iranian flags attacking an
Iranian consulate the visitor was there
to restore order but his presence
highlighted the protesters biggest
grievance whose Major General Kasim
Salima
sulemani head of Iran's powerful codes
force he had come to persuade an ally in
the Iraqi parliament to help the prime
minister hold on to his job sulemani is
basically backing the shadow government
in Iraq they the same Democrats who are
proclaiming the
Trump has been too soft in his
foreign-policy our simultaneously
attempting to cut a deal with the
Iranians they can continue to maximize
their power in Syria in Lebanon in Iraq
in Kumasi Stan according to one of the
leads Iranian intelligence cables Mahdi
who next I'll work closely with Iran
well Saddam Hussein was in power in rock
had a special relationship with the
Islamic Republican Republic of Iran when
he was rocks oil minister in 2014 the
exact nature of that relationship is not
detailed in the cable and has one former
senior US official caution a special
relationship could mean a lot of things
it doesn't mean he's an agent of the
Iranian government but no Araki
politician can become Prime Minister
without Iran's blessing so there is
something again if you're talking about
the partisan politics that play into the
impeachment inquiry there is something
to the Republican complaint that
Democrats are deeply worried about Trump
violating the protocols of international
diplomacy by creating unofficial
channels while at the same time the
media cheered on the Barack Obama State
Department and the National Security
Council being led by Ben Rhodes was best
known for writing crap novels that were
not but never published into Brooklyn
apartments before cutting in Iran Zia
lines the American people while doing so
it's a dangerous world out there and the
fact is that the Trump administration
has been a lot harsher on America's
foreign policy adversaries than the
Obama administration ever was so there's
a great irony to this whole idea that
Trump has somehow undermined American
foreign policy in dramatic ways while
Democrats continue to try to undermine
America's foreign policy in dramatic
ways another example of this Hong Kong
is now the subject of a massive
crackdown according to the according to
TNS news Hong Kong police and protesters
hardened their battle lines over the
weekend as violent clashes showed no
signs of abating leaving the city
bracing for a second week of upheaval
that risks disrupting pending elections
the weekend saw pitched battles with
demonstrators launching bricks and
Molotov cocktails and steel balls of
police who in turn volley teargas and
deployed water cannons a police media
liaison officer was hit in the leg by an
arrow while protesters tossed petrol
bombs at residence clearing streets
strewn with bricks police were preparing
to clear the remaining demonstrators
from Hong Kong's Polytechnic University
early on Monday morning warned they
could use live ammunition if they faced
violence soldiers from the China's
People's Liberation Army the PLA took
the rare step of leaving their barracks
to join cleanup efforts which added to
concern by some about China's growing
roll over the former British colony that
has fuelled five months of protests so
China is again trying to strengthen its
grip on Hong Kong Iran is trying to
strengthen its grip on Lebanon Syria and
Iraq and we are being told that the
solution to this is democratic policy
and the Trump has undermined American
foreign policy who do you think was
appeasing China for years on end both
administration's Intel Donald Trump who
do you think was appeasing Iran for
years on end that would have been the
Obama administration before Trump got
there who is appeasing Venezuela for
years on end it was the Obama
administration and the same Democrats
complaining that Trump is undermined
American foreign policy by setting up
unofficial channels in Ukraine they
don't seem to give a damn that Venezuela
has turned into an absolute hellhole at
the behest of socialists and that
socialists in the United States like
Bernie Sanders and Ilhan Omar continued
to provide a certain level of
intellectual Aid and support to the
dictatorial government of Venezuela over
the weekend supporters of Juan Y doe
staged their biggest protest in Caracas
in months as Venezuela z' opposition
leader seeks to revive his campaign to
oust president Nicolas Maduro according
Bloomberg when week after Majora's Ally
Evo Morales was topped in Bolivia Cueto
is seeking to boost thinning crowds that
have grown apathetic since a botched
uprising in April failed to remove
Maduro Venezuela has been relatively
quiet as quiet a lost momentum while
violent protests rack's Latin American
countries from Ecuador to Chile he drew
crowds of hundreds of thousands this
year but many followers now doubt he can
unseat Maduro
quite owes approval rating is down to
42% down from more than 60% so Maduro
has re solidified his grip and it
doesn't help that you have politicians
of the left in the united states who
continue to suggest that American
involvement in Venezuela not in terms of
military involvement but undercover
involvement support for the opposition
that that is in and of itself offensive
again all of this plays into how people
think about impeachment so impeachment
typically should all be about the
actions of the President and did they
violate his constitutional duties but
when people see impeachment what they
really see just like they have with
every poll question for years they see a
proxy for the broader culture war
ranging from foreign policy to domestic
policy from Colin Kaepernick and
chick-fil-a to Venezuela and Hong Kong
everything is wrapped up into a ball and
that is how people think of politics in
the United States and I don't think that
they are wrong to do so frankly because
the fact is
that we don't agree on enough for us to
simply focus in on what the president
has done right and what he's done wrong
if there was some sort of broad
agreement about what American foreign
policy should be if we agreed about that
sort of thing or if there a broad
agreement about what American freedom
looked like then the role of the
President himself like as a person would
not matter so much right then we could
all argue in favor of the idea the
president ought to go based on what the
president is doing or he got to stay
based on what the president has done but
when impeachment is just a proxy for how
much you hate the president or hate his
policies when you disagree with the
president and therefore you want him out
and even wanted that since day one it
makes it very difficult to take the
entire impeachment inquiry particularly
seriously so that is where things stand
as we enter week two of the Democrat
impeachment inquiry again the only
testimony that's gonna matter this week
you're gonna see a lot of headlines that
don't make any difference the only
testimony that matters this week is the
testimony of Gordon Sunland the EU
ambassador who is the only person who's
been in the room with Trump who will
have testified at this point in time as
they as push comes to shove on Wednesday
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then a quick thing that I hate and
we'll get out of here so things that I
like so there is a very good movie it's
it's about the it's about basically a
white supremacist / neo-nazi who has
turned from that point of view it's
based on a true story the movie is
called skin and it is quite good now I
think that it's important to recognize
that in areas where Americans agree
Americans agree and this is a perfect
example so this movie is about a white
supremacist who becomes a not white
supremacist with the help of the
Southern Poverty Law Center I think the
Southern Poverty Law Center is over
overall I think they're garbage I think
they routinely mislabel people as all
right when they are not I think they
routinely mislabel people white
supremacists when they're not I think
they conflate everybody who is right of
center with people who are violent and
terrible I think the SPLC overall does
terrible terrible work but in this
particular case I think the SPLC did
something really good and credit is due
when credit is due so the true story
here is that there was a natural white
supremacist and the SPLC helped this
white supremacist become an anti racism
advocate and also had an anonymous donor
who helped paid for this white
supremacist who heads all sorts of
facial tattoos to get those tattoos
removed so he could change his life and
make his life better that's basically
what this movie is about and movie is
quite good the movies called skin
a little bit the preview guys like this
only after Yosh diam life in prison or
they start talking
so laughs kick why oh my kiss to be
around us
[Music]
she lookin at ya mostly based on fact I
mean there there's some exaggeration
here and there but overall it is it is
based on a real story and what is great
about the movie is number one it shows
the evil of white nationalism which is
truly evil but number two it also shows
the capacity for human Redemption and
that is obviously quite a good thing
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so the New York Times went after FedEx
over the weekend why because FedEx it
turns out paid few paid less in taxes
this year than it did last year a lot of
that was a result of the Trump tax cut
and so the New York Times blamed FedEx
for the Trump tax cut the New Times
reported on Sunday quote in the 2017
fiscal year FedEx owed more than 1.5
billion dollars in taxes the next year
note noting what changed with the Trump
administration's tax cut for which the
company had lobbied hard wait wait you
mean that a company that wanted to pay
fewer taxes a tax cut was passed and
then they paid fewer taxes huge massive
massive news so what did they do wrong
according to the New York Times the real
problem is that FedEx had suggested that
they were going to invest a bunch of
money in new equipment and other assets
in the fiscal year that followed but
they didn't end up doing that so the
times had nearly two years after the tax
law passed the windfall to corporations
like FedEx is becoming clear
the New York Times analysis of data
compiled by Capital IQ shows no
statistically meaningful relationship
between the size of the tax cut that
companies and industries received and
the investments that they made well
that's not particularly surprising
considering that the vagaries of the
economy changed calculations all the way
through
FedEx CEO Frederick Smith has now
responded to the New York Times and he
just blasted them according to the Daily
wire he called their story factually
incorrect he claimed the New York Times
is the company that doesn't pay federal
income taxes and he challenged the
publisher of the New York Times to
debate on tax policy Smith wrote quote
the New York Times published a distorted
and factually inaccurate story on the
front page of the Sunday November 17th
edition concerning FedEx and our
billions of dollars of tax payments and
billions of dollars of investments in
the US economy pertinent to this
outrageous distortion of the truth is
the fact that unlike FedEx the New York
Times paid zero federal income tax in
earnings of 111 million dollars and only
30 million in 2018 18 percent of their
pre-tax book income also in 2018 the New
York Times cut their capital investments
nearly in half to 57 million dollars
which equates to a rounding error when
compared to the six billion dollars of
capital that fedex invested in the US
economy during that same year so in
other words yeah we've been spending on
investments but you double checking our
business investment calculations and
suggesting that it is corrupt for us to
attempt to lower our tax burden so we
can operate our business with more
profit is ridiculous because you guys
are involved in the same rent-seeking
activity of course that is 100% true
but this is all part of the New York
Times broader campaign to deal with Jew
demised any business that isn't the New
York Times the same way they see unions
do legitimizing corporations involved in
corporate spending on politics while the
unions proceed to spend hundreds of
millions of dollars on politics the New
York Times is hypocritical and good for
the head of FedEx for pointing that out
ok we'll be back here later today with
two additional hours of content or we'll
see you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup
is by Jessica alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]